it's great to welcome to the program
today Jack Lew who's the CEO of Wan
chain doing some very interesting things
in the crypto space Jack great to talk
to you today I appreciate it thanks so
much nice to be here so let's just start
with the problem that you've identified
in the crypto space which is not a
problem that my audience will be
unfamiliar with which is that kryptos
are effectively isolated on their own
block chains therefore there are a
number of barriers related to that that
prevent people from even getting
involved in the space let's start there
what does that mean what does it mean
that Kryptos are isolated on their own
block chains yeah I used the term in the
internet world in in the early days in
six to seven days there was an Internet
Bay and some computers are connected
they created something called local area
network sometimes it's even today in in
the company world you have intranet and
then once we connect all these
Internet's together or the local area
networks together we have internet so
that's why when we look at the branching
world today it's like Bitcoin seems like
it's global but actually they're like a
separate tribe they have their own
community they have their own language
when you can compare to YouTube or any
other blockchain community they all
speaking different languages
I'm not talking talking about you know
the communities you can have you cannot
join multiple communities but in reality
all these different networks they cannot
talk to each other so you cannot
transfer bitcoins alternative in the
network and vice-versa and you cannot
transfer information on Bitcoin to eat
mmm either right so
today we rely on some you know
centralized and vulnerable exchanges to
exchange value and this is really not
the perfect walk we want to connect all
these siloed siloed or we call tribes
together connect them together and
somehow we make them interoperable
that's a problem we try to solve
so let's talk about what it means to be
interoperable because someone who has a
little bit of an understanding of the
crypto space might hear us talking about
this and they'd say hold on David Jack
hold on a second here because if you
have Bitcoin on an exchange you can
almost instantly exchange the Bitcoin
for aetherium and then do whatever you
want with the etherium why is that not
enough
and why is what you're talking about
with one chain different right in two
areas right one is it's centralized
ready we in the blockchain go we trying
to become a disinterest right in the
central as well they're different issues
like one is in a centralized exchange
there are many different issues there's
manipulation records can be altered and
also phones can be stolen and they're
hacking event just oh I know every
exchange has been hacked before right so
this is the funds the you know the
regular could owners if they store the
value in the centralized exchange is not
very safe right so that's one the other
one is the centralized exchange they
only do you know cocteau exchanges you
do trading by this very simple function
and when we talk about interoperable
there are many other things you can do
pay we have to make the cocoa world or
Russian world it's programmable by you
you need to use small country
you can create you know very complex
you know derivatives or programs and/or
like some some kind of some
decentralized organization or like Dow
many other things you can have these I
totally build on this new internet of
blockchain so that's what the
centralized exchanges don't have today
do you think that this is one of the
bigger obstacles to broader crypto
adoption because we usually when we talk
about what's holding back adoption we
hear about price volatility we hear
about transaction costs on some block
chains we hear about transaction fees we
hear about sort of like a knowledge gap
that exists where does this lack of
cross it interoperability fit into the
barriers to adoption as you see it well
some sort I don't see that's a big
problem for adoption I think it just
takes time right there is some value for
centralized exchanges or some essential
centralized services and that's when the
traditional users they're used to it hey
there's some some drawbacks to it
eventually I think it takes steps we
gradually move into the world everything
all the different block chains are
connected to each other and we have
wheel we call it internet a blockchain
so tell us about the one chain wallet
what does it do how does it solve this
interoperability problem well well when
chain winston's for wide area network
right we try to connect with build
bridges between when chaining and other
block chains so just use one simple
example when she already is connected or
we have bridges to Bitcoin and the you
tinia right so
we need to have this when what you want
it like it you you said interoperable
wallet or multi coin wallet so in this
wallet as a user you have access to
Bitcoin um and also wenching so for
example you have the same wallet you
have some eating them or ethers I have
Bitcoin so both of us can deposit all
coins I deposit my Bitcoin until
wenching and you deposit your interest
on to energy and on one chain we can
exchange it in the decent-size exchange
you can do some trading over there or in
the program in the Dow the only
environment some automatically things
can happen right so in the certain price
you can get my Bitcoin and I will get
your ether and then we can withdraw just
like essentially as you can change we
can withdraw all coins back into own
wallet so in the in the in the wall
environment so you just click a button
and send it over and then to exchange in
withdraw so everything should be
seamless that's what we envision I wrote
down there I've read that one of the
aspects of this is that it will be
manageable from a smartphone without
dedicated hardware can you talk about
that a little bit yeah so small phone
[Music]
that's what we imagine why everybody is
going to use the small phone to do
trading is there's a benefit of using
that small phone basically you you know
you can have you know kyc you know you
know bar the way you are and don't you
have an information can be as into the
small phone hey so recently we have been
working with other vendors like
telefónica rivet and civic trying to
bundle them together and and use small
phone
to to do the the narrow use cases I just
described earlier so a small phone
there's a there's a potential issue that
it is not extremely secure may usually
you don't want to store a lot of a lot
of coins on on too small file you want
to use some kind of hardware or we call
it special hardware beauty into the
small file to ensure the security of
your fun and when you think about the
the various use cases a lot of the early
use cases seem to be within the crypto
finance space but is there the idea that
the usability would go beyond that in
the future yesterday I think definitely
would be on the financial area like you
know you can use your your phone or any
device devices and you can sign your
contract you can take a photo and upload
into a certain area in the decentralized
network and also secured in the
blockchain and all the information or
the legal documents or any kind of
information you can put on blockchain
make a you know and cannot be temper
right so and all the legal all the
reading any comments and many other
things they can all be built on
blockchain and and I think the use cases
beyond the financial areas just you know
compass III or as a wrenching on myself
III think that the financial area has no
value so right now in the first phase
and he says color phase we want to focus
on financial aspect of the parching
right now can you talk a little bit
about what's next on the roadmap in
terms of the next year or so yeah so
when she finished two point zero three
three points there were basically
the two biggest community of crypto
communities so far so at this stage it's
not a very user-friendly it's very very
early stage right and we want to make it
more user friendly and making seamless
and also increase speed by many things
we need to improve that's one thing the
other thing is for the enterprise world
we have the vision to you know build a
bridge between the crypto world and also
traditional financial world Hey so we
imagine in the traditional financial or
enterprise world there will be a lot of
and you know we called climate change or
consortium chains they will be used so
we try to build a bridge between
wenching that basically the public chain
with with the private chain so we
recently you know announced a
partnership with a company in Southeast
Asia and we try to build a bridge
between wenching and also private chain
so I think this is very significant for
us or you also the industry because once
we have the bridge or any asset we
imagine that all kinds of assets will be
put on blockchain right any traditional
asset they all be put on property and
once the comprise they can be bridged
into public between space and the only
way on the part of the public chain
space or the quick poll points they can
be exchangeable with the traditional
financial asset I think that's a very
important so that's 4.0 we we hold that
wenching for Pope can compress you that
you can learn much more about Wan chain
at one chain org we've been speaking
with one chain CEO Jack Lew Jack really
appreciate your time today and telling
us about the project all right thank you
so much you David